mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
two boats are on opposite shores of a
lake
each boat moves at a constant speed
each boat will make a round-trip journey
from its shore
the first time that the two boats meet
is 500 units from the left shore
in this round trip the boats do not take
any time to turn around
they move back instantly the second time
the two boats meet and pass
is 300 units from the right shore
the question is what is the distance
between the two shores of the lake
the second part of the question is what
is the ratio of speeds of the two boats
this puzzle is from the moscow puzzles
problem number 227
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem
so how can we solve this problem we are
trying to solve for
l the distance between the two shores of
the lake
to do that we'll keep track of the
distance traveled by each of the boats
and
the total distance traveled by both
boats
let's first take a look at the first
time that the two boats meet and pass
each other
this is 500 units from the left shore
so the first time the two boats meet the
black boat has moved 500 units
the purple boat has moved l minus 500
and if we add up these distances we get
the total distance by both boats is
equal to
l we'll then do a similar calculation
for the second time that the two boats
meet and pass
so this will be 300 units from the right
shore
the black boat has traveled a distance
of l
plus 300. the purple boat has
essentially made a round trip
but it's short by 300 units so the
purple boat has moved 2l minus 300.
we can add up these distances to get the
total distance by both boats is equal to
3l
we can now use this table to solve the
problem
notice the time between the first and
second meeting is the same for both
boats
furthermore each boat moves at a
constant speed
so it suffices to compare the distances
between the first and second meeting
the total distance traveled by the
second meeting is equal to
three times that traveled by the first
meeting since each boat moves at a
constant speed
this must also be true for each boat so
it's true for the purple boat
and it's also true for the black boat
this means
the second distance is equal to three
times the first distance
so we just take a look at the black boat
numbers
we must have that three times 500 is
equal to l plus 300
this means 1500 is equal to l plus 300
or l is equal to 1200 and we've solved
part of the problem
to get the ratio of speeds we substitute
l
into the first equation for the purple
boat we get
l minus 500 which will be equal to 700.
we can then compare the relative
distances to get the relative speeds
the purple vote speed divided by the
black bolt speed
will be equal to 700 divided by 500
this is equal to 7 over 5 which is equal
to 1.4
and that's the answer to this puzzle it
seemed like it would be impossible to
solve
but once we worked through the distances
it worked out like
magic thanks for making us one of the
best communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time